hello this is toasters Tampa architected
IBM for data and analytics in the cloud
and I'm going to talk to you today about
the sequel sandwich this is actually
about databases and object storage so
and as you can see in image we are
putting it together as a nice and tasty
sandwich so at the center of this end
which we have our data warehouse so this
is a very well-established mechanism of
storing and analyzing data big data but
we're surrounding it now with more
recent technology that is especially
popular in the cloud and this is object
storage and we have it as the buns
basically for sandwich at the top and at
the button
now what's the purpose of having all of
these components what we have actually
at the top is our initial place where we
are landing and storing our raw data so
this might be things like lock messages
from applications IOT messages from
devices that are just coming in and in a
pretty raw format we are able to just
store them at the object storage for
very low money little money and in a
highly elastic manner and in the data
where us however we want to have our
high quality data because the data
warehouses are much more sophisticated
but also much more expensive component
to operate a host and to purchase and at
the bottom again the object storage why
do we have another object storage at the
bottom well this is where we have our
archive data now all of these components
basically make sense in an end-to-end
big data analytics use case because we
have new data arriving and being stored
the object storage and here in the
object storage basically we are going to
explore the data so we try to find out
what's actually in the data and we prep
the data we prepare the data cleanse it
make it higher quality more curated and
we also conduct to some extent batch
analytics directly at the data that is
stored in the object storage and it in a
warehouse I ever basically we are able
to do interactive analytics
that requires certain as a lace for
latencies for performance response times
and so on and why are we having this
archive date again well this is
basically because you do not want to
keep all of this data for years around
and it awareness because as I told you
this is the more expensive thing to run
of all of these components so it makes
sense of the data for those data that is
not hot anymore that is not required for
your daily business to archive it off
off again against an opt-in to an object
storage so that for instance you can
still run things like compliance reports
that you're required to do to compete
could be compliant with certain
regulations so these are the different
types of analytics and things that you
want to do with the data at the
different stages of its life cycle
basically now of course a real sandwich
shouldn't be this dry so you want to
have some source in there so what is
this source basically did you lose these
things together it is basically an ETL
mechanism it allows you basically to
read data from here and transform it so
that it can be learnt and inserted here
and same from here to here so basically
data is traveling this way now finally
you see a sandwich is often something
that all it's typically something that
you do not eat in pieces right you do
not just eat the patty or just a bun you
read it as a whole thing so you consume
it as a whole thing and that's also the
same analogy that holds here that while
it makes sense to prepare a system that
can serve these different types of
workloads in a most efficient way and
cost-effective way possible
it's of course hard if you always have
to think about where I go here here or
here before this community it should be
mod automatically figured out by the
system and for that reason we are
putting this all into a nice box we're
putting it all together
and we are using Federation as a
mechanism on top of all of that that
basically virtualizes the HT location of
the data depending on its age or state
of the pipeline that it is in now
finally it's called a sequence and which
why it's called a sequel sandwich well
because simple is the essential thing
for all of these things that you can see
here sequel is used for basically doing
these analytics these are sequel queries
if we are running here sequel is also
used to do it ETL and finally sequel is
also used in order to federate those
things together that's a sequel
Federation ok
voila that's our sequel sandwich and I
hope this helps you to put in
perspective the roles of object storage
and data warehouses and how these two
things can be put together into this
nice and tasty format so that you can
get the most out of the technology in
combination thank you very much